[Musik]
wo anfangen wenn die Welt enttrümmern
liegt wenn das was das Zuhause war in
Sekunden ausgelöscht wurde die Kräfte
die die Überlebenden dieser Zerstörung
entgegen stemmen können haben derzeit
nur das eine Ziel diejenigen zu retten
die noch verschüttet sind und noch gibt
es sie diese Momente in denen Menschen
gerettet werden und die der Hoffnung
einen Schub verleihen die oder den
Liebsten nicht verloren zu haben
und damit willkommen zu diesem
zdf-spezial
mit dem Mut der Verzweiflung hatten
zunächst diejenigen die verschont
geblieben sind mit bloßen Händen
angepackt mehr und mehr kommt Hilfe
hinzu die besser ausgerüstet ist doch
dieser Trost relativiert sich in
Anbetracht der Ausmaße 23 Millionen
Menschen brauchen Hilfe Wasser Wärme und
die geborgenen und verletzten auch eine
medizinische Notversorgung alles
gleichzeitig und alles trotz der
zerstörten Infrastruktur
das staatliche Krankenhaus von
Iskenderun es steht nicht mehr ein
dringend benötigtes Krankenhausbett
begraben unter Trümmern große Teile des
Krankenhauses sind in sich
zusammengebrochen für die Menschen darin
gibt es noch keine Hilfe
oder ein Arzt hat gesagt dass da 15
Leute drin sind inklusive der Patienten
im Moment sind sie da drin gefangen
niemand kann sich dem Gebäude nähern der
dritte Stock wird kaum gehalten wir
warten auf schweres Gerät um zu helfen
alles ist zerstört
die Maschinen kommen aus den umliegenden
Städten dann versuchen wir den Schutz zu
entfernen
die 250.000 Einwohner Stadt am
Mittelmeer hat es schwer getroffen sowie
die ganze Region Hatay im Grenzgebiet zu
Syrien die Zerstörung unermesslich Berge
von Trümmern unter den noch Menschen
liegen
Rettungsteams vor Ort beklagen mangelnde
Ausstattung die Bewohner bemängeln die
nicht ausreichende Hilfe für die 10 am
meisten betroffenen Regionen im Süden
des Landes hat der türkische Präsident
Erdogan heute für drei Monate den
Ausnahmezustand ausgerufen das gilt auch
für die Stadt Adana zahlreiche Menschen
stehen hier Schlange um einen Platz in
einem der notdürftig aufgestellten Zelte
zu bekommen viele trauern und fürchten
um ihre Angehörigen
auf der syrischen Seite sind sowohl von
der Regierung als auch von der
Opposition gehaltene Region betroffen
etwaidlieb und Aleppo und damit auch 4
Millionen syrische Binnenflüchtlinge sie
leben ohnehin unter schwierigen
Bedingungen
kleine Lichtblicke wenn doch noch
Überlebende gefunden werden
so wie dieses Neugeborene in der Region
Aleppo
seine Mutter aber ist gestorben
insgesamt haben die Erdbeben ein Gebiet
mit 23 Millionen Menschen getroffen rund
5000 Tote sind bereits gezählt die
Überlebenden brauchen Hilfe so schnell
es nur geht
[Applaus]
die Beben machten dann keiner Grenze
halt Hilfslieferungen notgedrungen schon
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock
forderte heute Syrien auf alle
Grenzübergänge zu öffnen auch Russland
müsse seinen Einfluss auf das Regime
nutzen damit die Hilfe auch ankomme
derzeit gibt es zwischen der Türkei und
Syrien nur einen offenen Grenzübergang
und in Syrien bin ich jetzt verbunden
mit Fee Baumann sie leben dort und
arbeiten für die Hilfsorganisation
kurdischer roter Halbmond guten Abend
guten Abend im Nordosten Syriens ist die
Lage schlimm im Nordwesten noch
schlimmer wie schwer wird es ihn gemacht
zu helfen
ja so tatsächlich ist das Hauptproblem
das Hilfslieferung kaum ankommen bzw
wenn dann viel zu spät
wir haben gestern Nacht noch mal nach
Beben gehabt und trotzdem wurden weiter
türkische Luftangriffe geflogen in der
Region also im Westen Nordwesten bei
afrin
auch gerade in der Gegend die schwer
betroffen war von den Erdbeben und die
vorher schon auch von den Luftangriffen
schweren Mitleidenschaft gezogen worden
ist zusätzlich zu dem Erdbeben gibt es
auch noch Angriffe von Seiten der Türkei
genau genau auf jeden Fall gestern Nacht
in der Region dass es das was ich
bestätigt bekommen habe heute
gab es weiterhin Angriffe ich sagte es
nur ein Grenzübergang ist offen zwischen
der Türkei und Syrien besteht überhaupt
die Chance von da auch nur im Ansatz
genügend Hilfslieferungen
durchzubekommen also ein Grenzübergang
ist sowieso schon schwierig genug
da genügend Hilfsmittel rüber zu
schicken und abgesehen davon werden
diese Hilfslieferungen mit größter
Wahrscheinlichkeit die kurdisch
bewohnten Gebiete nicht erreichen die
syrische Regierung hat zwar einerseits
international um Hilfslieferungen
gebeten macht aber zu Bedingungen dass
diese über Damaskus ins Land kommen wenn
das so wäre käme dann bei ihnen
überhaupt noch was an
da haben wir das gleiche Problem auf der
anderen Seite
da werden die die Hilfslieferung auch
nicht in die kurdischen Gebiete weiter
ankommen bzw auch nicht komplett
die werden natürlich werden die die
Hilfsmaterialien auch da gebraucht das
will ich gar nicht bestreiten aber in
die hauptsächlich kurdisch bewohnten
Gebiete wird davon sehr wahrscheinlich
sehr wenig ankommen letzte Frage noch
kurz was macht ihnen in dieser Lage
Hoffnung
also jetzt gerade macht mir Hoffnung
dass es ein sehr viele sehr viel
Solidarität gibt aus aus Europa aus den
westlichen Ländern
das ist eine das ist die Forderung gibt
die Grenzen Übergänge wieder zu öffnen
und
am Ende hoffen wir auch ein bisschen
dass die Wahlen in der Türkei vielleicht
auch was ändern könnten
danke für diese Eindrücke direkt aus
Syrien
danke auch
und weil die Leitungen nach Syrien sehr
unsicher sind haben wir das Gespräch
kurz vor der Sendung aufgezeichnet und
wollen an dieser Stelle anmerken dass
wir von hier aus nicht verifizieren
können ob es wirklich einen Luftangriff
der Türkei in den zurückliegenden
Stunden gegeben hat
all diese Bilder der Zerstörung sind
noch schwerer anzuschauen wenn Familie
und Freunde betroffen sind verlässlich
zu erfahren ob es ihnen gut geht ist
kaum möglich wenn Telefon und Internet
ausfallen so geht es gerade vielen
türkischstämmigen Menschen hier in
Deutschland einerseits Warten und Hoffen
und andererseits wir uns Thomas münden
am Beispiel Duisburg Marxloh jetzt zeigt
Selbsthilfe organisieren und LKW
hinschicken
in Duisburg-Marxloh leben rund 14.000
Menschen mit türkischem Hintergrund
natürlich ist das Erdbeben bei Gaziantep
Gesprächsthema Nummer Eins auch wenn das
Leben hier ganz normal weitergeht
ich habe mehrere Freunde in der Region
nur teilweise konnte ich sie erreichen
ihre Häuser sind eingestürzt so heftig
war das
jeder versucht irgendwas zu spenden so
viel er kann
beten dass viele Überlebende noch
gemerkt werden und dann eigentlich
mit allem helfen mit Klamotten man hat
Unterstützung mit Geld mehr kann man
eigentlich von hier aus nichts machen
die Besitzer dieses Düsseldorfer Cash &
Carry Marktes kommen aus dem
Erdbebengebiet rezan Sattler weiß
inzwischen das drei Familienmitglieder
noch verschüttet sind
erst heute kam vielleicht von den
Menschen die wir halt am meisten
erwartet haben kleines teils Hilfe aber
zu großen Zeit wurde das von den Leuten
halt übernommen die da Leben und die
haben halt nicht die Kraft das halt
unter den Trümmern die Menschen da
rauszuholen ab jetzt wird in ihrem Laden
gesammelt für die Überlebenden in ihrem
Ort Schuhe Kleidung Babynahrung Windeln
viele wollen hier irgendetwas abgeben
die haben weder essen noch was zum
trinken nur was zum anziehen wenn da
aber keine Hilfe von denen kommt weil
das ja nicht ausreicht da sind zehn
Gebiete die betroffen sind muss man ja
als Privatperson sagen ich muss dahin
und meinen Menschen zu helfen weil wenn
ich es nicht tue wird es kein anderer
tun Haupt Problem dürfte der Transport
werden private LKW können im Moment die
türkische Grenze nicht passieren Familie
Sattler auf das vielleicht bald
Hilfsflüge mit privaten Spenden
organisiert werden
in der Türkei in karaman-marashes seit
heute morgen die Hilfsorganisation
adfire um Strukturen wieder aufzubauen
ich bin jetzt telefonisch verbunden mit
Tim Heunisch guten Abend was haben sie
alles im Gepäck
guten Abend ja neben den 18 Mann
Personal auch zwei Rettungshunde und ca
2 Tonnen Ausrüstung gilt es jetzt
Logistik wieder aufzubauen oder wie hat
man sich das vorzustellen wo fangen sie
an
also in erster Linie ist unsere Aufgabe
mal etwas Ordnung das heißt wir erkunden
die Stadt karamanas und nehmen dann such
und Rettungsmaßnahmen vor das heißt wir
suchen unterteilen nach für mich
Personen z.B mit unseren Rettungshunden
und retten diese Gegebenheiten geht es
in erster Linie ums retten oder auch ums
versorgen also unsere Aufgabe ist in
erster Linie das Retten natürlich dann
auch das medizinische versorgen der
geborgenen oder gerettet sind auch schon
ähm aber für die weitere medizinische
Versorgung gibt es dann andere
internationale Teams wie diese Aufgabe
übernehmen realistisch eingeschätzt wie
groß ist der Zeitfenster bei diesem
Bedingungen
naja also wir haben hier starke Windel
sehr kalte Temperaturen und Menschen
halten natürlich auch nicht unbegrenzt
unter Trümmerteilen aus
deswegen wäre es jetzt schon ganz gut
wenn wir in den nächsten Stunden bzw in
den nächsten ein bis zwei Tagen hier
eben weiter vorankommen und so viele
Möglichkeiten befreien können wie sehr
hilft Erfahrung oder ist jeder Einsatz
neu und auch aufs Neue belastend
Erfahrung ist ein wichtiger Punkt wir
konnten Erfahrung von den
verschiedensten einsetzen sammeln zum
Beispiel 2010 in Haiti nach den Erdbeben
oder 2015 in dem Fall aber auch in
Beirut nach Explosion und neben diesen
Erfahrungen aus dem Einsatz wird
natürlich auch viel Erfahrung aus
Übungen mit und deswegen ist erfahren
von einem sehr wichtiger Punkt trotzdem
ist jede Lage anders aber Erfahrung ist
trotzdem ein wichtiger Faktor danke dass
Sie sich Zeit genommen haben um uns Ihre
Aufgaben zu schildern danke schön
wenn sie den Menschen in Syrien und der
Türkei helfen wollen können Sie spenden
beim Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
IBAN
de6500
400-100-400 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben
Türkei Syrien das können Sie auch in
Ruhe nachlesen unter spendenpunkten
zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf Seite 890
in den betroffenen Gebieten steht eine
weitere kalte Nacht an und des Präsident
steinmeier sagte heute an die Menschen
vor Ort gerichtet in dieser schweren
Stunde sind wir bei euch wir warten und
bangen und vor allem hoffen gemeinsam
mit euch
das war unser ZDF Spezial hier im
Programm geht es jetzt weiter mit den
Rosenheim-Cops auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]